going to start and then we'll talk
anything you want to talk we're going to
put some music on then we're going to
[__] talk this will take you back
here this show is brought to you by
score big baseball season just started
basketball season's ending hockey
season's ending you're going to want to
go see games next time you go to see any
game or show go to scorebig first and
see how much you can save go to
scorebig.com right now and click on the
microphone it's right at the top it has
a red background and enter the promo
code Joey that's J OE Y and you'll save
an extra $20 off of your first order
that's scorebig.com and enter the promo
code Joey show is also brought to you by
headspace.com go to headspace.com jooy
rightow and download the free headspace
app and begin their take 10 program for
10 days of guided meditation that's
headspace.com joeey and download the
brand new headspace app and the show is
brought to you by hit.com go to hut.com
and use cod Word Church to get 10% off
all of the great optimization products
alpab brain new mood TR Tech immune TR
Tech Sport and I am about a week into
the Dolce way the banana almond it's
delicious go check that out it's on
it.com promo code
Church
[Music]
what big shout out to my main man L my
[__] mic there blower that and thing
it's too hot there you go there you go
what one two one two oh [__] it's
Wednesday [__] little shout out to
Bobby Sharon sending me a street songs
by Rick James here you go
[__] oh
[Music]
[__] you hit those you hear that
[__] [__] kidding
me if you're not getting up [__]
ripping your clothes off jumping up and
down oh
[__] oh [__] oh [__] this is smooth
right here you're over at Biggie Smalls
club and American Gangsta oh
[__] oh
[__] what are you going to do Lee we got
to open up one of these clubs in Israel
and get these [__] started it's
the Church of What's Happening Now
[__]
Wednesday April
6th what's going on uh what's happening
Brother I can't call it Herb Dean in
house today I always call you Herb Dean
it's Herb Dean her it's Herb Dean herb
whatever the [__] I'm terrible what's
going on with you Lisa had a great
morning I went and worked out a little
bit did a little work it's great you're
looking good give him the crab on c c
give the crab stand for the crab sure
what the [__] give him the crab show
them who that [__] oh [__] oh [__]
smooth you got to do it every once in a
while let these [__] know know
who's running things you know yeah it's
uh it's I oh I wanted to tell you I I
texted mother friend who who didn't get
back to me and he he didn't respond to
the text but I put it out there again
last week we're were talking about uh
just losing touch with friends did you
call his [__] wife no I didn't call
the wife call the wife stop texting this
[__] half a [__] and call the [__]
wife explain your situation say that you
don't know what's going on youve text
them you didn't know if he got hit by a
car and you're worried about him then
they'll tell you what's going on if she
don't call you back then right send them
a [__] you letter and say go [__]
yourself and your [__] friend you took
my friend from me you little dirty [__]
and move on with your life how was your
day tremendous but it happen Lee it
happened so a man listen man a woman
will tell you a man will [__] snake a
woman along till the wedding date and
then rules
change and people have to accept it when
people get married that college [__]
goes away that that thing is my mic is
too high here my ears I think it's just
your ears that that that that
uh that you know it's tough to stay
friends when you have children a
marriage a job right loans you're trying
to work on something God forbid you're
trying to work on something if you just
have a job 40 hours and a
girlfriend that you see four nights a
week what time do you have you have
three nights those three nights you got
to work out you got to clean your
apartment you got to do laundry how much
time do you have to go to a bar and hang
out you can't get drunk no more on a
Tuesday when I was 21 I could drink 92
beers and snort 84 lines on a Tuesday
and be up Wednesday ready to [__]
stab a [__] if I have a beer now
on a Sunday I don't recover till
Wednesday I don't
drink yeah it's not as fun anymore it's
not it's not that it's not as fun you
try to everybody tries
to keep it going keep it going going but
your body falls apart eventually you
know I saw somebody last night at The
Comedy Store I didn't recognize them I
hadn't seen them in 10 years but I
didn't recognize them and they had
alcohol on their breath you know they
never stopped
drinking that's crazy it can change
someone's body it can change how you
look change everything they were swollen
their nose got bigger their face got
bigger you
know it's whatever you can't you can't
live that lifestyle forever you know you
have a girlfriend you have
responsibilities you can't go to a
[__] bar and cause Pro you know it's
always the same and people don't accept
it that's it people get busy yeah yeah I
I've had some friends like that you
[__] work on the weekends okay you
you you you have a plane ride that
starts on Friday right and you don't
come home till Sunday and that's uh out
of 52 weeks Let's do an estimate of 40
weeks or 45 no way 40 4 at at least at
least 40 to 45 weekends he works he's
gone so he basically has 4 days a week
to make it happen cuz Sundays are WAP
Sundays are WAP you get off the plane he
don't sleep in hotels like I you don't
get 9 hours in a [__] hotel either
it's too warm it's too hot to pillow it
don't feel
Gooding so you really sleep shitty one
night you recover the next no that's
that's one thing though is I can sleep
just about anywhere I sleep on the
planes really good I see you I see you
on the planes [__] right out yeah but
still sleeping on the plane is like
sleeping on the [__] Twilight Zone
yeah okay so when you get home on a
Sunday it's a wash you're tired yeah I
just want to relax have a you relax you
got the girls the wife asked you 20
[__] questions you got to answer
emails from the [__] weekend you know
actually no the girl's no more so I'm in
empty nester my daughters moved out
really yeah uhhuh yeah yeah so um my son
he's been hasn't been living with me for
a while he lives with his mom though and
then my daughter 19 years old they're
out they're doing their thing yeah one
they're nothing really out they're like
okay so they live with their aunt one
with her mom's sister the other one
lives with my sister okay and they're
doing their thing one you know they're
you know she's going to school and has a
job the other one just got a job and uh
trying to see if I can keep her out of
trouble that's tough yeah that's tough
it's tough man work job but the point is
that you have four days yeah you have
four days to make it her happen her de
every week you don't have seven like
most people you have four here so you
have four workouts you probably have
ations yeah I got my projects you you
know you have your little things going
on and then somebody wants to call you
at 2: in the afternoon and do lunch yeah
yeah I got I got like it's right in the
middle of my [__] day once I do lunch
after lunch what do you want to do you
want to take a [__] nap so these are
the things you get busy well I I hear
you Joey talking a lot about oh I
actually can do some work on the road
cuz you don't have some of the those
distractions do you get some of that
done on the what is your daylight herb
on the road before the fights because
the fight day is pretty much all day but
if you're there a day or so early right
so yeah you're actually right sometimes
I do I am able to get some of that work
done I sometimes I just sit in the hotel
room I go through the emails answer the
emails I do scheduling stuff I do work
I'm supposed to do you know that I that
I don't want to do at home so yeah a is
good for it sometimes I do the same I I
I bring a computer with me that's not a
great computer so I don't trust it to do
something tremendously on I trusted to
tweet and maybe Facebook and maybe check
my messages I don't [__] with that Lit
lift in there when I write I don't [__]
with it in that cuz for some reason
something goes wrong and I'm [__] but
when I go yeah I got three four hours in
the hotel room to sit and write comedy
you know if I'm thinking of a TV show
and I'm writing it I'll do it then I
like all that stuff tell you where else
I stretch out believe it or not on a
plane those long flights I come [__]
prepared do I got everything in that bag
everything I need you know what I'm
saying everything I'll bring the sides
with me to go over if I have an audition
now so you can you can um you can work
well on the plane I'll throw that
computer on and check messages and I'll
go on the plane with a project every
time I go on a flight longer than three
hours I know I'm not going to sleep so I
have a project but if I get on a plane
and [__] Rocky is on you know Creed
that throws my plan off like the last
flight I got on on the way back I
usually don't plan nothing cuz I'm fried
from the night
before yeah so no me on on the plane I
can't work on the plane I try sometimes
I bring it every now and then I'm able
to get a little bit in but I can
probably get in about 20 minutes here 20
minutes there as soon as I start
concentrating on a plane it puts me to
sleep I had a friend whose dad was a
consultant and went to Europe like back
and forth from Boston to Europe every
week and he said that was the only time
he got work done because he don't could
call Un un un the best riding you'll do
and that's is what works for me I get
high on the plane like before I get on
the plane I get pretty stoned I eat an
edible I eat the breakfast I focus and
then I take the notebook out and I leave
it open I take the thing out I leave the
notebook open with a pen and I watch
whatever's going on I play music mhm and
I let the music or whatever I'm watching
dictate what I'm writing do you are you
with me no no okay no sometimes I'll get
a joke sometimes let's say I got to
write a letter to Phil Foley I'll write
on the
you know my buddy's in college he's
doing some time at a college somewhere
so I have to write him letters in fact I
owe one you know I plan all those things
do you have like a different style or a
different band for each activity like is
comedy one music is writing another
music is no I just put an album on and
I'll listen to you know listen man we
get I love music right I love music you
know I was trying to push a music show
but music is very tough to sell we live
in a in an age that right now if I'm
driving and I go dog when was the last
time you heard a re the Franklin uh what
was the song we played last week I
forgot all about that song we played a
re the Franklin last week uh I'm
blanking on the name [__] song from
71 just tremendous I hadn't heard it
since my mother had the bar in [__]
Harlem right right you know I hadn't
heard that song I mean I was dve with my
wife and I heard it un
serious in today's world what song is it
let me look it
up oh you got to hear this [__] H
this is this is a the yeah but you know
something yeah you're right if you're
doing creative stuff you can yeah on the
plane is a good time sometimes I get so
caught
up in the
uh in the music that I realize how
brilliant the music I'm listening to is
and how much effort they had to put into
this music that that inspires me yeah
like I start thinking about how Rock
Steady go ahead that's a great song
listen to this [__] when was the last
time you heard this song this is just a
[__] amazing
[Music]
song come on oh no she goes in come on
just I got tears I get this will never
happen again this will never happen
again
[Music]
ever sit yourself down in your car and
take a ride while you moving
rock I could see her just the way she's
singing opposite the beat that's what's
killing it listen to
it
feel and she's riding a little bit to
the back she's riding to the back yeah
and then she drops thear Franklin right
[Music]
here all right I'm on the plane
listening to this and I'm thinking
listen to how sick my mind this people I
want to learn where you got the balls to
come up with this okay I cry I want to
know I want to know where the [__] you
got the balls so I think of the black
composer put this together right cuz
that's all ARA Franklin worked this is
Funk do you think it's a dude that
looked like uh like this she she never
work with the Swampers well you know I'm
just thinking to myself like who came up
like who come up to AR Franklin was it
some dude that looked like uh uh
puff puff with glasses or was it some
bad black [__] that came into
studio with alcohol and his
[__] bread he just said re the
Comm for a second and she's like I ain't
got time for this he's like listen you
got to hear this fun guy came up with
and he just started with this base that
that's what I think about who created
this Baseline it wasn't some [__]
genius ARA Frankin wrote it yeah oh no
no According to some dude she pays for
did it say who played on it let me look
for it you know that dude came in and
said arita listen to this [__]
[__] I got hit so I was I was just in U
Memphis not too long ago so I went to
the stacks Museum you ever go to that no
oh you have to go to the stacks Museum
so it's the stacks records right you
know stack okay now I know what you're
saying okay so Stacks Record so
basically you know it's it's a more
Southern Soul so there's like mtown out
of Detroit and then there's Memphis
Stacks man it's man if you're ever in
Memphis you got to go now who came who
was on the stacks L okay so I think AR
Franklin did some stuff on there not
sure exactly but I think she did but um
definitely Isaac Hayes uh salmon Dave
Otis reading uh you know Booker and the
MGs uh I said I said Isaac Hayes a few
other people so all that stuff was on
stacks and it's a you know it's it was a
little it it was a it's definitely
interesting you learn a lot so they did
that whole uh oh who was those girls the
um the Nets something the Nets no those
girls who uh they they did that song
they did songs with Earth Wind and Fire
Earth Wind and Fire was uh was out of
there came out of there yeah uh but they
did songs with Earth Wind and Fire and
they uh they did that big concert down
in Watts after the riots watt Stacks
it's a lot of stuff to learn about uh in
that uh Museum all that stuff there's a
documentary on muscle shows uhhuh on
Netflix and I saw part of it on the
plane that was pretty interesting about
what bands have gone through muscle
shows now did did AR ever do anything
with them I think so because there's
something on there look for ARA and
Dwayne alond listen to this [__] yeah
this to this [__]
somebody sent me this on Twitter last
week and I I had never known this
existed and I [__] it sounds great
arita Franklin's tremendous so yeah this
is when a reita you know with [__]
Dwayne Alman how do you get that
combination
[Music]
togethering
I I just need some crazy [__] can lay my
head hey mister can you tell me where a
girl might find a bed can you tell shook
my
hand all
[Music]
it and this is with Wayne
Alman yeah yeah there's a couple of
there there's a couple jams on there
it's called the weight so yeah this just
uh so much music history that there is
to be like if you I would plan a trip
around muscle shells really yeah my wife
would go my wife would do it in a
heartbeat with the baby she would do it
in a [__] heartbeat that's more of an
education just going through there and
sniffing that [__] air are you
kidding me so do they have a museum or
anything like that down there that shows
about about the studio I'm not sure I'm
not sure what goes on down there is that
in Alabama yes the stones were there
like just a lot of people went in there
you want to smell those [__]
it's like you go to The Comedy Store
that's that's Richard prior stage just
breathing there does something to you
you know it does something to you so you
were saying like that the music show was
difficult to pitch like what was your
show since the music is so great like
what what is so difficult so many
copyright companies so many different so
when you have an album it's not about
the album it's a different writers on
every song so all I need is one writer
on one song to say I don't want my song
on that [__] show and I can't do the
album on the show but the the beauty of
it is that we live in a society now
where if I could listen to that song I
could go on my thing and I'm serious it
says the song and the who did it so I'll
say rock steady and the read to Franklin
at the next light I could go on my
iPhone go to iTunes and buy the [__]
song okay and not really get the essence
of the album right do you know what I'm
saying every album has an essence you
that's that's something I've been doing
a lot lately so sometimes in my morning
like in the mornings people I Tweet
songs out that's all great Joey but
you're not doing nothing for me
because to really get the full
experience of that song you got to see
what comes before and after when I tune
when I play a song it's like me giving
you the scene from The Godfather when he
shoots [__] the the guy at the table
Michael colone goes to siisy you can't
watch a movie like that an album is a
[__] movie and and the bands like
again and you guys are going to go [__]
you Joey you're an old [__] I'm telling
you that these bands listen to the
thought process they had into the covers
there's also a thought process on how
the music comes up how they want you to
hear it what they want you to hear
before that song and after that [__]
song and and Pink Floyd definitely did
as we heard today with animal con they
con they just you know they they filled
it together I've always felt that you
know uh I heard a [__] great song
this morning and you guys are going to
laugh at me what's the chick that one
Miss America and they stopped her from
eating
[__] she was married to Rick Fox from
the Lakers come on [__] guys I don't
know
running back to
you do good
things sh you Vanessa Willam Vanessa
Williams Vanessa Williams put an album
out in
1991 right somebody gave it to me like
somebody gave me Vanessa Williams I
always thought Vanessa Williams is
[__] beautiful I just love that
that's what a Cuban woman looks like
when they're mixed like that they got
that malata blood I love all that [__]
they do that's what you call them mados
that's what they called in Cuba m
that's what they're
called so I I took I put the [__] CD
in the car out of all the music I like
Vanessa Williams album I don't know why
and it that album that had running back
to you and uh and you know go
revisit I do remember she
had one thing about that album was it
was all themed that album was a con like
she wrote about love or whatever she was
singing about in that [__] album her
revenge or her Freedom you know Pat
benit talk Crimes of Passion listen to
that [__] album listen to that side
one that's planned the that the last
song is a song you hate hell is for
children remember you hate that's the
last song on the album you know album
was called uh the Marvin Gay with I want
you on it what I
think you know you listen to the best of
but then you go back like I just went
and listened to that album um yeah a
couple weeks on a plane on a plane you
know I bought it before I got have time
you don't have time in your normal life
so what I do on a plan is I go to
YouTube I plug the speaker in and I
listen to a whole loud and I go wow that
was [__] tremendous something we have
forgotten in this country listen to the
whole Al well now there not thought now
it's all about mother you got eight
songs that's why this chick has a song
every six weeks she sucks a dick uh the
skinny blonde with the [__] disease
what's her name is it [__] uh that's I
want to say Taylor but it's Taylor Dane
whatever Taylor Swift Taylor yeah
whatever the [__] you got to assume
she's got a disease she's always skinny
and pale and she got SS on her lips
she's got something you know what I'm
saying she blew one of those dirty
[__] actors or something I never knew
that
brutal I never knew that albums were
like an entire theme or I thought it was
just songs put together because they
they like the songs I didn't so if you
listen to like the songs that we
listened to before on
Periscope does it is it different for
you if you only listen to one song
versus the whole album do you feel
different yeah yeah oh yeah and there's
music like the stones the stones did
location [__] music so the stones
would call each other and go hey it's
time for another album boys what do you
want to
do I don't know let's do well let's go
down to Jamaica and hang out with Peter
TSH and we'll hang out down there smoke
dope we'll rent the house and we'll
[__] do an album down there so it's
the feeling that they were thinking
during those eight songs yeah if you if
you're a real Music Guru and you go back
you'll find out that sometimes they'll
put seven songs together and they had
two songs in the previous album that the
company will make them put on their
fulfiller or something like that but the
essence of those seven songs you'll feel
you'll see what songs don't belong there
you and you know whose point he did it
beautifully Marvin Gay when Marvin Gay
released I want you that was a piece of
[__] Marvin Gay that'll never that
was the best Marvin Gay so all those
songs and on that album that's the best
Marvin Gay I mean the better Marvin Gay
was the one after the one before that I
think oh no yeah yeah sexual uh feeling
whatever that was after sex I think uh
before before that was like you know
stuff like the
ecology right uh I'll tell you who else
did a lot of albums that if you listen
to we get cheated the Youth of today
gets cheated Stevie
Wonder Stevie Wonder put listen Stevie
Wonder put out four songs
four albums in mtown towards the end
with mtown that they're like Pink
Floyd's strength ending with songs in
the key of life in 76 ending with a
double album okay so if you don't buy
those albums whole and listen to them
you know there's just some people Judas
Priest
uh British
steel Judas Priest British steel is a
[__] phenomenal how you know breaking
the law the other one then one goes into
the other one uh Metal Gods it's [__]
brilliant does it matter if you don't
like a song on an album like let's say
it's your favorite album but one song
you just hate will you still listen to
it or do or does it affect your opinion
of the album or not really uh no no no
listen man you're not listen when I put
an album out not all the jokes you're
going to like not all the [__] jokes
all right you're not going to like all
the goddamn jokes so uh but there's
going to be six to seven jokes that
you're going to go oh I get this now he
was talking about this there a theme
what I'm trying to write an Alum first
thing I got to write on a piece of paper
is what am I trying to
say what am I trying to say with this
album if you watch the 70s on
CNN uh Motown was putting out a
particular sound for years and
[__] your boy went in there and said
listen I'll [__] put on out but I I
don't want to use the BAM Brothers no
more I want to use I don't want four
brothers behind me [__] jigging it up
I don't want that I want to tell you
what's in my heart he put that song out
about the war Marvin Gay yeah yeah
what's the first one did uh what's the
it's uh mercy no no it's the not Mercy
Mercy what's going on what's going on
and that broke the bank that broke the
bank that that that invaded thought you
know he spoke about the war and all this
[__] Stevie Wonder went into mown and
said hey I want to do what he's doing I
don't want none of this [__] little
Stevie Wonder no more I'm a grown
[__] man I've eaten [__] I smoke
dope I'm just blind that's it but let me
do it my way and he did his four albums
you know that's you know they wanted to
break out of the mold that was their
mold for them and by that time who cared
M Michael Jackson was about to [__]
sizzle the goddamn [__] world anyway
in 1971 so and he broke the bank with
that first St ABC what I want you back
and all that [__] but we don't do that
no more was so accustomed to serious I'm
I'm Hey listen man I'm the first guy
that fought in the car I have serious on
there and I [__] love it I got disco
54 I got Groove channel 50 which is that
medium range I got metal [__] I got
Aussie's Boneyard and I got lithium I'm
good to go lithium is sound guard and
Allison Chains that era and uh and I
listen to individual songs speaking of
music I I would be slipping if I didn't
tell you my son just put out an EP so
I'm band camp are you serious yeah
Aladino Hotel it's uh he's doing all the
guitar on it mainly and uh it's kind of
like a Indie pop thing it's good stuff
though man man he can he he writes good
music the name of the band is aladina
hotel that's a complete different
[__] gift writing music and doing all
that type of [__] I don't know how the
[__] they do that I don't know how he
comes up with this stuff like he'll
teach me some of his songs like how did
you think of that yeah how did you put
that together you
know it it was very interesting I only
you before the show you were speaking
about the show vinyl and I've only I
only saw the first episode but it they
were talking about uh the main manager
had one of his first clients was an
African a black client who he like
screwed out of like they made him go
under like a pseudo name and they
wouldn't let him record the songs he
wanted to record right they made him
play Little Jimmy little so they made
him play like you know B Holly but this
[__] could shred a guitar and
play Blues right so now he comes back
and now he's a manager he became a
manager of a [__] punk band
but they fired to of the punk rockers
and they can't come up with a song and
in one scene this guy [__] goes give
me the [__] guitar the white dude
goes what the black dude goes give me
the [__] guitar he takes that Strat
cast from him and he goes AB e ebi
whatever AB these chords have lit the
world on fire and he starts playing
every song that's those three chords M
like every song that's been written with
those three chords he goes this is how
it starts and he's singing all of them
and and all a sudden he just goes into
this blue song and it rips the room
apart and he puts the guitar down he
goes figure it the [__] out and he walks
out of the room kid comes upstairs and
goes hey man all those songs You Did in
ebi those are some the El songs but that
last song who wrote that and that's how
that's so now he's going to come into
his own because the guy's badass right
and and they beat him up or something
they beat him up they beat him up then
the mafia beat him up because they own
the record label
so they wanted him to be little Jimmy
black little some dude who just sang
with four black guys behind whatever he
don't want to do that he wants to do
[__] BB King type [__] you know so
yeah three course you probably talking
about gcd huh something something ebf
ABD and he keeps saying this is it this
is how you write a [__] song okay all
that other [__] don't care he goes here
he goes and he start playing it and it
was like 20 songs 20 songs he just kept
going kept going
this is it this is the way you write a
[__] song I would love to be able to
write a [__] song one song I would
die I don't I don't even have the heart
I don't even know where they come up
with those lyrics I have no idea where
people come up with those lyrics we were
listening to Lenard skinnard the other
day uh Whiskey Bottle brand new car oak
tree you're in my
way who who who does that who does that
too much Co and too much
Mo look what's going on inside you who
writes that ooh that smell can't you
smell that smell the smell that
surrounds you who writes that who writes
that that's something that you think
about people look at this [__] junkie
he's going to kill himself and sure yeah
that's what he's writing about his song
his brother crashing the [__] car who
comes up with these lyrics who sits
there and goes who the [__] sits there
the other day I was in the car I was
brought brought to so much emotion I was
listening to the white dude
he's from Detroit Michigan on the L Lans
and
Highway oh I know you're talking about
oh yeah Bob Seager Bob Seager yeah yeah
what what was that dude thinking listen
listen to that
jam on the road are you [__] kidding
me he had to be writing this on a bus
sitting there going on the road again
here I aming star again are you [__]
Turn the Page Turn the Page are you
[__] kidding me who writes that type
of [__] D I could never do that I'm
Blown Away by the by the music cuz like
I lyrics I can I speak English but
just yeah but think about it like this
the to make all those instruments sound
like that it's mind-blowing I I can't I
I I tried for one summer to play guitar
but my fingers were too too short and
too uncoordinated I couldn't do it but
it's that like that's the part that I
can't that just blows my mind like the
the especially bass recently you really
like guitar every time you put a song
with like good bass on I don't know why
I just I just sit there stoned and think
just thinking about how someone could
even like cuz with words you can think
about putting words together I can't
imagine putting notes together and then
putting the guitar with the drums with
the with the organ with the whatever
they have yeah but when you put the
words together you got to put notes
together too and you know what music is
MMA you put in the band the [__] you
putting Jiu-Jitsu wrestling everything
together it all comes together at some
[__] point man it's really crazy how
music an art is an art is an art yeah
what to me what's crazy about it is how
how these how these sounds and these
rhythms and these notes bring emotion
from your body and make you want to
bring move your body to him you know
what I mean and and that's a universal
thing I think that that blows me away I
saw this crazy video it was a some they
had dementia and they couldn't talk this
this old lady and a nurse sang church
hymns and she came out of it and just
started singing it was it was it blew my
mind it it's crazy like like there's no
reason babies should dance like babies
don't know what music is exactly exactly
right like does does mercy like any
specific songs now like think yeah just
day one she's been moving moving and
grooving man it's amaz yeah you're right
when she was a kid she loved the little
legs would go off and and now she dances
I catch her dancing by herself and [__]
you know it it is the expression of it's
it's I love it I don't know what I do
that's that's the way you could instead
of throwing me in prison just go you
can't hear music no more I would die so
you're you you you you did write a music
show an idea huh for music I tried it
was just not a music show it was like a
a concept where I take a musician and we
go to a record store and pick an album
that that made him [__] want to
everybody has an album that made you
want to jump out a window you know
everybody everybody has that one or two
albums that you go especially when you
talk to your musician when you talk to a
slash and go can I talk to you what do
you like and he'll tell you albums that
influenced him and you're like I get it
now I get it you know he liked AOS Smith
so what do you think he's going to play
Aeros Smith plus which is what Guns and
Roses is Aeros Smith on [__] steroids
that's all they were Aeros Smith on
steroids they just blew up Aerosmith you
know they had that Aerosmith dirt dirty
[__] feel to them so you ask you know
when I when we listen to Chris Cornell I
guarantee and this is without having a
conversation with Chris Cornell not that
I know him I'm just saying this is
without having a conversation without
Chris Cornell if I walk into Chris
Cornell and I take him to a record store
one of the top three albums I guarantee
he's going to take is something from the
Beatles okay I hear the Beatles in his
music so I know he's going to take the
White Album or uh the one with the
Tomorrow Never Comes That Crazy album
when they first started [__] around
with drugs yeah there there is a a lot
of Beatles up in there and and you know
what also I hear a lot of and all that
stuff from up there was a a lot of Black
Sabbath a lot of Black Sabbath I
guarantee all those well especially
again Kim sayal I did see an interview
one time where he said when the first
time he heard shelding of the Grave his
head almost blew up and that's what made
him turn the cords around you know all
those guys all those great guitar
players will tell you that they did some
to have that sound you know uh uh we
were talking about this Tony iomi from
Black Sabbath his fingers got cut off in
a sheet metal accident that's why
whenever you see pictures of Tony iomi
he's always covering his hand go ahead
go to you go to Google p go go to Yahoo
and go pictures of Tony iomi he's always
covering his hand because he lost his
fingertips so it's the right hand or the
left hand one of those so for him to
play the guitar he had to put special
caps on his fingers so he couldn't get
the chords so he had to turn the cords
upside down or put base chords on his
guitar
that's what creates that sound with
Black Sabbath
so see he only show the see the picture
he has the the pentagram and the whole
thing he has like fingertips right
okay in the earlier pictures see he
would never show his
hands in the early early iomi pictures
he never showed his
hands and that's why his guitar is so
[__] different because he had a turn
he used bait
strings instead of regular guitar
strings that's why the guitar is so
heavy H this is very interesting a lot
of those guys theyve Gilmore probably
did something there was somebody else
who I just read did something like that
he turned his guitar around or he did
something weird to get that uh that
thing around I want to ask you something
that me and that you went to college no
didn't finish no college no finish and
all your
uh experience with the body is through
just martial arts over the years yeah
yeah martial arts over 20 years
experience yes yeah done a lot of
martial arts and you started here in la
oh yeah yeah yeah I started um I started
doing martial arts with uh Frank tro um
he was a we did some kickboxing so I
when I was a kid I did some karate and
some boxing but first time I did
anything full contact was I was like in
88 I did uh started
kickboxing now you were telling me that
the the school that uh Enter the Dragon
that's still there the school and enter
Dragon where Jim Kelly goes in the Kempo
School the BTK Brothers what do they
call them they're still there was it you
that was telling me I don't think it was
me who was telling you that they're
still there you know it is huh that
school's still there like and it's it's
deep in Anglewood oh okay oh so it's the
bkf school or something it's a it's a
Kempo School call something they call
him something and uh it's down there in
Englewood somebody was telling me the
story recently I bet I bet it is yeah
because uh did he say it was a bkf
school black crowy f Federation cuz they
had kmo schools I don't know but it's
all black I do know then go with it I
mean you don't you know there's no
Mexicans in there this is all black
school but that's still there I was just
wondering if you knew those guys ear now
you knew my friends the the the Earl
white and his brother you know Earl
white another guy that teaches Kempo he
teaches uh Juan hop quendo down in uh in
Hollywood you know those guys okay no so
I here's I I went through with Frank
Treo I did know some of the bkf guys
trained with some of those guys and uh
yeah and that's how I that's how I
started getting into martial arts going
full contact was was through him but
some of the a lot of the bkf guys came
out there and trained with us uh like um
Ray rard uh Ray Daws um who else a lot
of the guys who trained with uh Steve
Muhammad who was the one who was the
main guy from there who was Steve
Sanders back then call Steve Muhammad
now what's the bkf like what is it from
the black Karate feder that's that was
just the it was the organization was was
a lot of martial arts who were all black
black guys and it was a it was a
federation did they fight against each
other or they just were like a group it
was just a a group and it was they they
did really well in a lot of the
tournaments they did I mean they they
were yeah they were
successful that's that's inter so where
like where did that come from were they
not allowed to do karate before was it
was it I just think it I just think that
it was um like yeah not not not allowed
but I think that you know back in that
time if black people did something you
usually had to get together with other
black people to do it you know you know
the martial arts scene really exploded
during the Bruce Lee years
and I had two karate teachers and both
of them were Vietnam Vets it was kind of
weird like both of them came back from
Vietnam and started teaching karate or
some form of martial arts or style you
know and when I first joined karate it
was a black teacher it was rashan's
father the Eddie student and he it was a
goj karate it was a black [__] ghee
and in those days 70% of the school
school was black you know it was a
couple white dudes and me and maybe
another Spanish kid or something like
that but it was all black and it's weird
like right now here in town they have
Disciples of Moses Powell okay yeah he's
a big Judo brother big [__] heavy set
black dude from the city that developed
his own style of Judah was supposedly a
[__] savage or something like yeah
Moes power yeah he's a beast so uh he he
has these students out here now one of
them is a black dude one of them is
Vinnie
cesare and Vinnie I know Vinnie from The
Comedy Store and whatnot Vinnie had a
school right down the corner right on
Burbank Boulevard on the other side of
lancas and Vinnie had a school for about
2 years but they got busy with movies
you got to close it and it's not that
it's a black Federation it was just
schools that are from Harlem yeah they
just you know they were from
uh not low rent areas you know [__]
uh some of the guys that were uh that
you know used to train and do a lot of
stuff with the bkf I mean the guy one of
the guys who managed a lot of those
teams that you know they weren't all
black guys but uh yeah it was just a it
was a group of martial arts that's yeah
but I think but at at the same time I
mean you said you were born in Cuba but
how how old are you 53 53 so if you were
born in the states when you were born so
we our our country has changed a lot cuz
when you were born if you were born in
the States you black people who were
born at your age had different laws
governing them white
people at that time at that time if you
were born your your age not 70 but no if
you're 53 so I'm 46 I was born in 70
okay so I have sisters who are eight and
six and eight years older than me when
they were born they were born with
different laws than I was born in which
what and what black people could do and
what white people could
do Unwritten no no written laws written
laws and yeah and then Unwritten so I
lived in Unwritten laws so yeah yeah if
you're doing stuff like yeah but like
that's our country has changed a lot and
people don't realize how long that it
wasn't really that long ago you know
that you know my sisters who were you
know just a little bit older than me
were born with different
laws do you ever think like 64 is when
it changed
right that's when they that's when they
that's when they moved some of those
laws on
yeah do you ever wonder like what we're
going to look back on and think about
how like how backwards we like we look
now back on civil rights like well that
was crazy that there were different laws
and I don't I don't know what it is
maybe it's gay marriage or I don't I
don't even know what's even after that
that's going to be the next thing that
just you never know I mean there's
things that I think that um that I think
about I think are just bizarre that they
have them as laws but you never know
what's going to what is going to change
or what are the things that we do you
know like when you when people when we
used I grew up smoking and we grew up
where you could smoke everywhere but now
that we've lived without it see what
you're saying no no no oh laws yes yes I
thought you meant Unwritten laws for
black people like when I was growing up
what's an UNR law if you saw like a
black people at the pool what the [__]
is going on there you know what I'm
saying see black people but I'm yeah but
I'm talking about written laws those
were written laws in ' 64 the the I
believe the laws changed in '
64 like you couldn't go here you
couldn't go there like like I thought
you meant like what black people don't
do and can't do like you won't see a lot
of black people skiing you won't see
black people playing hockey I thought
that's what you meant you know I
remember going to Florida when I was a k
did and you know my uncle I try to break
as many of those rules as I can yeah you
have to break those rules you I try to
get on my white boy get my wife I
remember my uncle was a Cuban dude he
wasn't racist at all nothing I remember
him going to me me didn't they don't be
say in laa because in Miami in those
days you know it's 100 degrees you
wouldn't see one brother at the beach
and when they were at the beach and we
saw three brothers but they were in the
shade I remember I was like seven my
uncle goes look Three Brothers in the
beach is [__] up cuz they us don't go
to the beach when it's hot like this I
didn't I thought that's what you meant
by Unwritten laws no I said I said laws
you put in Unwritten Unwritten okay I
didn't know like Unwritten laws that I
didn't know about ABS [__] lutely
absolutely absolutely I still
remember I still remember walking with
this young kid to go get James Brown
records when hot pants came out mhm my
best
friend Jasper Williams and me we G like
50 cents and we went to get the single
it was 50 cents you
know I don't know if it was racism like
we had a walk from 127
Street to like like 16th Street in
Broadway like we were young to do that
you know that was that was Unwritten
yeah 11 blocks 11 blocks that's
Unwritten like you can't do that and I
remember A Beat cop stopping us on the
way back and now always thought about if
that was like years later I always
thought about that was racism like me
walking with this black kid and the
white cop stopped us and didn't take our
money or nothing we were [__] six he
just wanted to know what we were doing
what was in the bags right do you know
what I'm saying I never thought about
that till 30 years
later 30 years later that I think was
that a racist thing never thought about
at that age you know it's so weird when
you're young you don't even know what
racist you didn't know Jasper was my
friend I didn't know if he was black I
didn't even look at that that didn't
even [__] matter to me years later
was when I realized holy [__] that's how
come I know all about this music cuz of
Jasper that's why I know about mfsb and
all that early stuff because of Jasper
and Joe Tex and and the re to Franklin
[__] uh you know but it was I don't
know I didn't know nothing I didn't care
I I came from a society my mom I can't
somebody but I thought years later that
the reason me and him got shaken down
that day was because he was black that
you never know I mean we have a we have
an amazing country I love me I love here
and we have a lot of uh a lot of
diversity a lot of cool things you see I
was just in uh Dallas over the weekend I
got to go to um well I was in Fort Worth
so I went to some country bars and
listen to some country music it was cool
you know I hav got an album I bought the
guys his CD he's doing some songwriting
man but yeah you know at the end of the
day like man those stuff like that
doesn't happen as much anymore it's been
years since I got dwb except for last a
few few months ago what's dwb driving
well black wa get dwb then a man the
other uh I was in San Francisco and I
was my friend of mine was driving and
and the police pulled us over and he
said well there something came back with
your plates that said you know Alabama
he said well I live on Alabama Street
that's why it says plates and he says
okay well we just thought you know the
plate funny we saw you pull over we
thought you guys were going to run cuz
it was a stolen car cuz the guy had a
BMW W and I said well but well why'd you
run the plates to begin
with and the plates were fine he didn't
have an answer we just said as soon as
you're finish just let us go and that
was a bummer of an experience but you
know yeah it
happens cuz he didn't give him a ticket
there was no law broken he just ran the
plates and then saw him pull over and
thought oh they're going to break for it
yeah the countryes changed a lot man but
not really but really yeah not really
but really yeah yeah yeah it's weird huh
you know what I'm saying not really but
really that's why you said Dallas I
thought you going to come up with a
story you know uh Texas is always a whiz
of a story when it comes to that kind of
stuff and behavior and but everywhere is
you don't know he but the bottom line is
I was I was hey I was doing my thing I
had fun I enjoyed myself down there in
Dallas and so that I I would think that
the country has changed quite a bit do
you think they compared to what other
Generations went through do you think
they've really changed or they've just
stopped saying it out
loud no I think I think that people
generally have changed I think that I
think that our country I think that
right now is a time where we have this
thing where all this stuff's happening
on the internet but until that was
happening I felt that our country was a
lot less racist than it than it was in
the
past I've had I mean I've got to go and
travel a lot throughout the South I'm
from California I got to travel through
this sport I've been blessed with being
able to travel to all these crazy Poli
places throughout the world but even
through places in the in the states that
I would never go to you know what I mean
so like Evansville Indiana or or or or
Jasper Alabama and I've had great
experiences in a lot of these places
that I would have never thought was
possible if I thought uh if I based it
on what I was taught about you know some
parts of this country now let me ask you
this when you were at this country club
last week this uh country music club I'm
sorry Country Club were there all were
there some other brothers in there no no
I was the only one you were the only one
I was the only
one you know it's just uh I live in I
don't know I live in a
50/50 MH type thing like I said to you
things have changed but not really I
still feel it not towards me I'm not I'm
just saying that I feel it at times like
and I'm not even black and I feel and
see different things and and I just it's
not that I turn my face away it's that I
just what are you going to do what can
you do it's something that you could
jump up and down about for weeks and
nobody either you get it or you don't
you know sometimes it's taught at home
when you're a child sometimes you bump
into two or three your [__] idiot
friends when you're 13 and it influences
you in an early age but besides that you
know it's just something that uh in my
world like the way I see it the way I
see things and I you know yeah I think
you just got to do your part right yeah
yeah you know I don't know I don't know
that's why I figure it was my part like
I could go to to to Fort Worth and go
and experience a places just like what I
do in LA but I would miss an opportunity
to see like a whole part that's going on
in this country and I felt like I was in
another country in this place in Fort
Worth so I was like man that was a cool
experience it's funny how what Society
perceives you know they
want like I think sometimes and we've
all heard that expression where like
Julia serving for example like you know
when I was a kid to my to me Julius
serving was everything soon as I saw
Julius I was hooked I liked everything
about him his
interviews whatever you know
and it's weird how I had other friends
in Jersey that they would say things but
they like Julius right they like Julius
cuz he was Julius they would say other
this [__] like we had to play [__]
pison east side or we had to play
[__] uh uh one of the scariest things
I ever saw in my life was I had to play
bitty basketball in Neptune New Jersey I
was never scared of black people till
then dug that was really real that is
real I don't know about Neptune oh yeah
that that [__] is deep you know Camden
them brothers you know and I think about
places like Cen like deep deep the only
problem ever and I'm telling you this
people 53 years old I did time in prison
and the only [__] bad experience I've
ever had with an African-American was in
Camden New Jersey Camden New Jersey they
don't play they just don't like [__]
Whitey they don't care if he's Cuban
Arab they just don't like Whitey you
read about over the years how the police
force quit there that's a different
[__] thing police force quit couple
years ago there was so much [__]
crime in Canon New Jersey since I was a
kid since I was a kid that's the only
place I've been beat like they took my
[__] money like they took it like
they didn't give a [__] that's the only
place where I saw a guy in a wheelchair
and the basketball player's name was
Dennis still I'll never forget this from
Canon New Jersey he ended up going like
[__] know the Dame or something but
in the final game northb and beat Camden
when we were in grammar school and
Dennis still spitting that guy in the
wheelchair
face you know he was just a crazy black
dude that that that's it you know but
that's the only bad like [__]
craziness experience and I've been in
some [__] Dark Places dog I did drugs
for years I did [__] time you know so
I don't even know what my point was I
got to stop smoking weed here
but it's weird what people perceive
people see uh uh who we talking about
before on [__] Terrence Howard oh
yeah right you know what I'm saying and
they think that's the way you know
people really don't know and they don't
want to know a lot of people don't know
I went to ten I went to puga Kentucky a
couple weeks ago I was in a
restaurant and I heard people [__]
saying PE things about Arabs like out
loud just that like a
like some lady said to me where you guys
flying in from LA and then they started
talking amongst themselves in the table
next to us about I don't know how people
get on planes with all them Arab
terrorists and [__] like that them
[__] towads I mean they were
going off Jack
so you know you I see it I still hear it
I still you know what I'm saying I still
[__] feel it from times hey and I'm
like I said a thousand times I'm
racially sensitive from time to time I
say some [__] up [__] well it's it's
it's it's there also because there's
there's there's a difference there's a
difference between I think
there's you know there there are some
some things that and there stereotypes
and some of them are funny and some of
them are fun to be along with but am I
going to um am I going to are are you
going to judge what what opportunities
you would put for someone or how you
didn't interact on it based on it yeah
you know you know some my friends might
make fun of me for different things like
that but that's just I think there's a
difference between fun and and then
making some policy on it you know has
anyone ever accused you dean of being
racist in like a fight decision I get
accused of everything in a fight
decision so I can get accused of I I've
I've been accused of everything yeah
what like what's the weirdest one like
what's like one that just when you saw
it you like what what are they talking
about I don't really remember a lot of
them because most of them don't come
from anybody that I that I take an
opinion of like if you if you uh cuz
when you say accusations I'm thinking
like maybe internet or something like
that and yeah I get accused of um yeah I
get accused of all kinds of strange
things or and and people come up with
with conspiracy theories that they know
are that they know to be fact is what
they believe and yeah so but I so I
don't I can't remember one off the bat
you know right off the top I hate
bringing this up again Le I know you're
going to get mad at me you watch uh
people versus OJs n okay so I don't
watch TV oh you better start [__]
watch I got to start watching I'm
missing out on some good [__] huh TJ
versus OJ Simpson and what else what's
the other one what's that other one oh
vinyl vinyl okay some so TJ vers I heard
it's good man well the thing about it
showed me something I didn't know I
didn't know we know I on paper OJ was
[__] guilty on paper you got to be an
idiot if you don't think he's [__]
guilty they did a great job defending
him but in the defense they did expose
something they did expose the racism and
LAPD and but at the end it's really
funny at the you know how they did it
was they they they they [__] got the
jewelry downtown and they got more of a
black jewry with OJ and the speeches
were great last night but it was funny
at the end OJ's sitting there he looks
up and as [__] uh the last jural
walks out he turns around he gives him a
black power [__] sign he walks out
and today they said that in real life
that juror was a black power
guy no wait wait didn't you grow up here
D he grew up here that's why what were
you thinking during all that I want to
know I when I was thinking during all
that man I I guess you know the day of
the verdict it was really that bad out
here okay the day the verdict like
nobody was at work no yeah yeah nobody
was at work um there people were
watching I tell you I remember when I
was I remember I cuz I you could listen
to it on um you could listen to it on on
the radio you were 27 years old right
something like that 26 20 years ago yeah
yeah probably like I think that's how
yeah maybe 26 25 26 yeah I think so wait
what do you mean so people just tell
their boss like I can't come in it's OJ
people were I think people were in bars
watching it people were in [__] bars
Oprah had it live it was on [__] Time
Square like people were stopped for the
verdict like that was it like they they
[__] the media turned this into
something yeah you know I forgot all
that I remember I remember yeah I
remember I remember I was listening to
it I I and I yeah it was a it was a
weird thing thing it a weird thing it
was it was a weird thing because I think
that like it was it was cool to see LAPD
exposed so you know because hopefully
that something was going to be that uh
since since it was it was different than
the way things normally go it was cool
to to see the LAPD exposed and know that
maybe they were going to clean it up and
I think they did I think it did there
was some good done behind that you know
say Hey you know anything that goes
there it's corrupt you can't take
anything out of there you know well ITW
Mark Ferman you know but Mark Ferman I
mean there's still allegations to [__]
with LAPD till this day I see some
[__] up [__] you know Le been to call
me when I yell and scream at him because
they do some [__] up [__] LAPD well I
have to say that the police experience
around LA area has gotten a lot better
than it was when I was growing up here
in La so they there some something
definitely has changed the way the way
they police yeah like growing up around
here police were I mean it was I mean
police were were yeah and all these
suburbs everywhere everywhere down La
Pasadena uh out everywhere yeah yeah
yeah when you see the police pull you
over you do not know what kind of
experience you're going to
have yeah it's that scary it was and and
and it's not like I don't believe it's
like that anymore I've been pulled over
three
times and the cop that gave me the
ticket was a black cop on a motorcycle
every right to give me a ticket I was
talking on my phone I was not
disrespectful to him and he was not
disrespectful to me the other two
cops uh were not disrespectful at all to
me they were white you know they let me
go on a warning you know was on one of
the highways and I know on Fridays and
Saturday nights if you speed on the
highways in LA and don't drink they just
let you go with a warning if you if
you're legit because they don't have
time to sit there with the [__]
ticket M so if they look at you and
you're not drunk you drunk you're doing
10 over the speed limit they'll ask you
you told them the truth tell them you're
sorry they'll let you go there was a and
two times I didn't have my license on me
and they let me go with no nothing how's
that one for you cuz for years I drove
without my license why because I didn't
have one I lost on a plane and it was a
Colorado license so I was scared to get
my California license so for two or
three years I didn't maybe four or five
years I didn't have a license how did
you get on planes an ID Colorado
ID who do you think you're dealing with
some [__] novice you think he just
you know you think I just fell off the
[__] raft it's I I've only been
pulled over a few times but one time it
was like the first time I ever got
pulled over they came around the side
like it was two cops in the CR they had
the flashlights and I just it was like
right when I got my license and I forgot
to turn my lights on as I was leaving a
convenience store so but it was like it
was whenever I hear anyone talk about
about not knowing what kind of
experience you're gonna have with a cop
it scares the [__] out of me too it
scares but it doesn't compute I just
don't it just doesn't make sense to me
cuz I was lucky enough to never really
have to deal with with them judging or I
don't know I don't even know what the
word would be but that's crazy well I
think between that between the O and and
the Rodney King thing and a few other
things I think that they they had to
come in and clean it up I think you know
they had to change what they were doing
and uh and I'm glad they did it's a lot
better yeah that case is that cuz
Joe you always make uh comparisons to
MMA for comedy and everything that trial
I I haven't watched like the last three
episodes but the that trial reminded me
of MMA because the beginning of it all
they're talking about all the
prosecution is talking about is how much
of a slam dunk the cases how they got
them how how they're going to destroy
them and then just little by little just
OJ's lawyers are chipping away at it and
then I got up right to the point where
they did the glove and it it it almost
look like with like wazzi getting kicked
Conor mcgr what any upset like that it
just seemed like oh they were just not
prepared at all for the hard a harder
worker it just it was that I I didn't
know I knew he got off but I didn't know
the intricacies of the case until I
started watching the show the part I
wish I could have been there to see was
remember do they do they do they do this
in the show um where didn't one of the
um one of the guys from the prosecution
have a have a have heart problems in
like uh back in judo's chamber when they
doubled he was back there with the two
guys I guess it seemed like they I mean
had heart attack like were they did they
did they talk about they showed the
heart attack in the beginning he they
lost them and Chris Darden replaced him
right now did they was how did it go
down was it depicted like these guys are
hammering with so many questions and he
just got stressed out they cracked that
dude they cracked him they just you know
he was a white dude he was out of his
league and he ran up against the Yankees
you know all that you learned from from
the OJ thing now compared to 20 years
ago that I saw in in in full effect now
was you can't have four [__] uh Ronda
Rousey they're GNA beat anybody you know
what I'm saying that's what they went
and got got the allar team had the
allstar team they got Barry sha uh the
other dude go whatever his name was and
the other white dude that's crazy the
black dude that's crazy Johnny Cochran
Johnny Cochran they had uh what the
Kardash Kardashian Kardashian but he's
dead mute you know he was worthless so
you had him but the Geniuses in that
were Alan dtz was the Alan dtz was the
game plan but uh who did Nathan Lane
play that was the the the Marine he's
the the Sammy the Bull's attorney for a
while he was crazy that guy's a musler
that guy's a bully that guy was the one
that they don't he's the one that asked
Mark fman have you said the word [__]
have you ever he goes off in court have
you ever said the word [__] how many
times have you said the word Nega it's
like 10 questions it's like so have you
ever said it when did you say it are you
calling these people a liar have you
ever said it would you ever say it and
he just going crazy he just tormented
him so they couldn't that D that first
white dude couldn't take it these guys
were coming in for they were coming in
for the kill that that Barry Sheek guy
became a [__] Savage you know he was
a DNA Savage they they they swayed the
jewry they pushed him into a different
direction it was too late they pushed
Mark Ferman so deep and even last night
he goes in the the fall of 1985
something began it began when they went
up to the steps and he was beaten and
all a sudden Johnny cockman said you
know what began 1985 the first time Mark
Ferman was called to Rockingham and he
saw a white woman running and he saw her
black husband and if you read his
Memoirs he says he pulled couples over
all the time so he found the two gloves
he just painted the
pathom you had eight or nine black
jewers they were OJ's a hero in the
black community listen bro let me tell
you
something here's the thing about OJ that
you don't understand Lee that he was a
hero in my
world he's a movie star like nobody
wanted to believe it everybody Lov those
and they showed that last night even was
he shaving the the Jew the cop coming up
to him in the jail and going so today's
the big day he goes listen I got a
friend over at the hotel you have
nothing to worry about he was a white
dude and he goes listen if I don't get
to see you anymore can you sign this
football for my
son I mean that's what you know
everybody love do J Lee Lee he played
football but everybody loved him he said
the right things he the right SM he had
everything he had everything going no no
and you know I'm a criminal so in my I
had heard before that he had beat her
never registered didn't care had nothing
to do with my situation at the time
didn't even judge it I wasn't there I
know that sometimes and when couples
argue [__] could get heated I didn't
know that he was beating her on a
regular and it's also a big step to go
from beating to murdering the cops got
called over there like 50 [__]
times so this is the cops fault from day
one if they would have arrest them see
30 years ago Lee if you and Paula got
into an argument mhm and she threw a
bottle at you and you grabbed her on and
said Paula get a hold of yourself and
the neighbor called the comp the comps
will come over
one would take you to a room and one
would take Paula to a room Paula would
say you didn't hit her that she lost her
money and through a a glass at the wall
and
um that she you you would you didn't hit
her you just held her
hand the cops would talk and they come
to you and go can you do us a favor can
you just go for a walk for an
hour just get out of the house yeah just
get out of the house can you go to a
hotel for the night
there's nothing happened here this was a
misunderstanding against two couples Lee
got home late a lot of stresses on the
wife she threw a glass but the neighbor
heard
it you done go to jail today you go to
jail yeah that's Thea somebody has to go
to
jail what they say on cops because it
has to because that's what happened
after OJ I got arrested for domestic
violence and nothing I didn't beat that
woman you know me why would I be
it was domestic violence because me and
her boyfriend fought and while we were
fighting she tried to break us up and I
pushed her
away and that's still domestic violence
and it just tripled after that huh but
when the cops came they took her and I
in the room and she didn't know she goes
did you get hurt and he goes well when I
was rushing them I got pushed away who
pushed you I don't know it could have
been Joey or the other guy we both got
arrested because there was something in
evolved and that all happened because of
OJ really so you think the entire legal
system was changed after that
wow because they had to deter it yeah
you have to deter it if it's if it's a
rotten relationship let's put somebody
in jail and let's make you [__]
really think about this is this what you
want with your life is this piece of ass
worth this [__] jail but now you're
on
paper so once you get in trouble with a
girl with domestic violence even if it's
something that simple you're done you
might will break up with it because it
escalates and you're going to keep going
to jail and keep getting arrested that's
what happened to me it escalates it
keeps escalating there's two there's
certain people that don't belong
together and sometimes when when
anything when it gets physical you got
to once it gets physical you can't you
got to go you got to go that's it
because it's not it's only going to get
worse that was one time they're going to
promise you it's never going to happen
again it only gets worse and if you see
it coming like if you see
it with your life yeah so that's what
happens so before OJ you wouldn't go to
jail if you didn't punch her in the
[__] mouth and hit her in the stomach
with a kick you're not going to go to
jail if you just argue with her and you
she pushed you and you pushed her and
you took the phone out of her hand or
you took the luggage out of her hand
you're not going to jail you know what
I'm saying now you go to [__] jail
that's terrif it's like OJ must relive
the entire thing every day there's no
way that a day goes by when he doesn't
think about not killing what whatever he
did to them the
trial I figure it this way I'm a
criminal I know what it is to do things
to people and to feel bad even if it's
the simplest [__] thing even if it
was just taking $50 from them I know
exactly how bad it feels but I also know
how it feels when you get away with
something is it good or
bad it's a good feeling but unless
you're a [__] idiot unless you're a
[__] idiot you know you're going to
pay for this so your life becomes
something else now they show him getting
acquitted last night and he goes home H
and in the van he's like baby you know
he thinks it's a year
early when he gets out of jail OJ they
only showed 10 minutes of that last
night but it was very interesting
because it was like that kid that goes
away after high school to college and
comes home for Thanksgiving back to the
bar where they used to hang out at and
he thinks that everybody's still there
partying and [__] so when he gets out of
the van he's like back in where did he
live brenwood brenwood yeah yeah he's
like the mayor of brenwood is back he
goes this was the case of the century
tonight's the party of the mother
[__] century and all a sudden he
looks up and there's a thousand people
with signs
murderer and that's when he starts to
get it and then he goes back to his home
and there's a million people there with
signs you [__] murderer you know then
he goes into his home and his familyes
there and I'll tell you I know exactly
what it feels like to get out of jail
you feel like you're in the [__] [__]
Twilight don't like time Stood Still but
it didn't like it stood still in your
head yeah and he goes in the shower and
he comes out and in this show last night
which was really good that's when he
realized what he had done H when he came
out of the shower and sat down was where
he broke down and his son comes in or
whatever then he goes to his party what
another thing he didn't know the party
that he threw MH was he got $400,000
from Star Magazine to take pictures at
the party
so that's when at the party 400,000 to
take pictures live at the party wow so
this is when that when he was toasting
they made him say a toast and that's
when Rob kadashian realized he didn't
want to talk to this guy no more and he
goes out to see Rob kadashian but before
that something happens he goes to his
son he goes make a reservation for the
Rivier restaurant book it for 10 people
better yet 15 the more the merrier and
his son comes back and he goes dad the
riv R said no and he goes why not did
you talk to David D tell David it's for
me goes I did talk to David and he said
they don't want your kind in
there so when he got out of jail he
thought he had a victory and he even
says to to his buddy where's Marty
where's Joey where's Tommy and the the
guy makes up excuses for all of them so
he might have won but he [__]
lost you know and shortly after that he
moved to Florida and he continued then
he moved to Vegas and he got involved
with that so karma naed him I mean he
got away with a double murder this
wasn't a drug dealer's [__] COK stash
or a box of gum you got away you threw
out two double murders into the [__]
Universe what do you think's going to
happen that's how long did it take for
all that Media stuff to die down so like
the case ended was it month was it weeks
another year because now because now
they interviewed the the jewry to find
out what happen why they made the
decisions all the little stories did you
ever get sick of watching it on TV I
wasn't listen at the time I had read
about it and I you know I was trying to
be a comic though I was living in a
[__] office on top of a Mexican bar
in Seattle paying 100 [__] out of
window because I didn't have a bathroom
in the building you know I wasn't
worried about the OJ trial at the time
as much as this was the show I just
started watching because I thought it
was an interesting topic and I wanted to
see how they would shoot it really oh no
it's well then maybe for you for me yeah
I I well I I don't think I spent that
much time watching it you know if I I
mean but the thing about it it was it
was one of those things that was hard to
escape it's one of those things that's
on everywhere you know what I mean it
was on the radio so you know you you
kept the breast of it but I didn't spend
a lot of time watching it I don't you
know I didn't sit down and watch it and
you could see at the end that was
something that I had forgotten that at
the end they showed the people hearing
the verdict verdict and they showed all
they split screened it and they showed
all at the time the real time they took
the real footage oh yeah that's right
and you could see people like going you
know and all of a sudden not guilty when
he said not guilty all the black people
jumped
up and white people sat there
like you know and they showed packs of
black people they showed crowds that
were they showed crowds that were mixed
the news the news were doing black
people jumping up and down and they
showed White audiences by themselves and
them like holding their heads like
[__] white women crying and [__] and
then they showed packs of black people
[__] like going crazy like when
Biggie died the riot they caused in
Brooklyn when they played the limo they
play this music and [__] it was like
that like so sometimes you win but you
[__] lose you know Johnny Cochran
died of [__] cancer after that uh the
other guy died a brain [__] tum as
Johnny Cochran the other guy Kardashian
died of cancer you know I mean it was a
big [__] scam you pay for your
sins you know it was a it was a [__]
M it was a wild experience for those
people the jurors they were sequestered
for a year a year yeah a year and you
can't work that's I don't think has
there been in trial like that since I
don't think so a [__]
year when he was walking around after
and that's how it ends it ends with him
looking at his trophy with him looking
at a statue him his BR statue in his
living room in his yard he walks out but
I I relate to the part of getting out of
prison and not when I got out of prison
I had no
uh No Reservations I knew exactly I was
walking out to I knew I was going to
walk out to indifference and people who
were my friends weren't going to be my
friends I knew this going in I knew
people who were mildly friends of mine
were not going to talk to me now the
people that were friends with the drug
dealer definitely didn't [__] [__]
talk to me like I had people tell I'm
friends with Buyers the guy you robbed
or whatever and they wouldn't talk to me
so there's always a problem when you got
out of prison so but I did my time I had
nothing to worry about you know what I'm
saying he got away with [__] murder
he had a lot to worry about look it
caught him three or four years later W
how long it take him to go back to
prison couple [__] years he was out
maybe five years people are after him I
think he got set up right some guys um I
think some guys asked him to go get they
told him yeah you got some your stuff
over here we're going to go get it back
with you but I think they were recording
him while their things were going on so
they they're like okay they were like
his accompli but they're actually
recording him to turn him in so I think
everybody was kind of gunning for him
that's what I heard at least yeah I saw
an interesting thing today I saw and
this is what my wife said my wife said
the same thing she saw the Jon Jones
thing and she said right off the bat he
got
profiled and he got pulled over she goes
trust me my wife is white and my wife is
a gentile she knows nothing about the
criminal line
and my argument was Lee was what was my
argument with you Lee what the [__] was
he doing that okay that's the bottom
line 11:49 at night you're married you
got two kids what the [__] are you doing
out when you're on [__] probation you
know what I'm saying with a [__]
$2,000 car you following me you're on
probation a $2,000 car a $200,000 car
$200,000 whatever the [__] he was
driving reving High whatever the [__]
he's doing you foll me yeah I think five
out of 10 cops will pull you over 1149
if you're revving because as I found out
a week later when you rev your engine at
a light that's drag racing yeah I didn't
I didn't know I didn't know that either
so today he said that he was being
profiled and then a couple days later
that cop has been reprimanded for black
profiling
before but what let's get to the bottom
of this why did this all happened
because he was out of the house at 10 to
12 and you're on probation is he on a
curfew no but when you're on probation
you're on an intelligence curfew because
you know that Anything Can Happen OJ got
set up but he knew exactly what he was
going to do any yeah no he knew he was
going to do he knew he no no no no and I
love OJ I tell you right out from the
heart I'm I'm just agreeing with the
fact that everybody's kind of was was
gunning for life was setting him up what
he didn't know OJ was life was setting
him up life gave him a big pass all he
had to do was move to
Florida date black
women you f me now date black women keep
your mouth shut don't let nobody take
pictures of you and he would have gone
away and eventually something would have
happened to him he would have lost a leg
in a crocodile accident playing golf he
would have walked back to put then that
that's something would have happened to
him he didn't he stayed the juice
everywhere everywhere he went I think
they people were people were he did
cocaine he stayed the juice that drama
followed him he didn't have that drama
before he killed Nicole he had [__]
drama before he killed Nicole but he
didn't have that Karma drama he dated
some chicks you accused him of doing
blow he started doing tons of blow in
Miami he got the 33 it didn't stop you
know uh it followed him but it's not
like today I was thinking about
something before I got in the shower to
come down here I said I had a good day
today I did some good things today and I
started thinking about how sometimes you
have a bad day and you have a good day
but you control that good day you you
can control your good days listen if you
get in your car and it blows up there's
nothing you can
do nothing you can do dog it's not your
[__] fault if you get in your car
right now and the battery's dead and you
got a meeting at 4:30 that's not your
fault that [__] happens you know that's
why you drive a newer car you get
tuneups you know uh if you don't pay the
that ticket on your car for
$28 after three months they're going to
to your [__]
car they're going to tow your
[__] car so you're going to go
out there right now and your car is
going to be towed and you're going to
want to blame being here being with Joey
Diaz no no no no you didn't pay your
[__] ticket from the beginning you
knew you got to pay the ticket that
would give you a [__] warranty you
got pulled over for a speeding ticket
you don't pay the ticket you say you're
going to go to court you failure to
appear you get pulled over you're going
to go you're going to go to jail you
can't blame it un [__] Lei at or your
wife didn't mail the ticket but that's
we always blame something you know what
I'm saying we always blame some I love
Jon Jones love Jon Jones I'm one of his
biggest [__] fans man I love Jon and
I he's 20 [__] six you know what 20s
mean that you could [__] up that's what
20s mean for me I I did time I went for
jail to kidnapping I didn't know what I
got involved in for him he went out had
a couple drinks snorted blow hit some
lady got scared and ran away that's a
[__] you do when you're [__] scared
and there's drugs of it's mistakes it's
called mistakes you can't judge a person
for making
mistakes but don't blame everything on
you know he was out of 10 to 11 yeah
well the last one this last incident I
mean I don't know any of this I you know
I don't really worry about him I try to
not focus on that type of stuff but the
last one I you know we I wasn't there
you know it's like I wonder how that
happened you know I wasn't there none of
us were there yeah but I tell you what
dog in 36 arrest and I look in your face
and tell you I never spoke to a cop that
way and Jon Jones's three brothers and
they've all been gentlemen every time I
met them mhm I know they're tight with
the mom and I know he wouldn't talk like
that way he wouldn't have called him a
pig if the guy wasn't accusing him a son
the other excuse I have for John is
maybe when I got arrested and I turned
myself in they told me to kidnapp I go
what the [__] are you talking about
kidnapping I didn't kid I didn't call
nobody it was no Ransom note I didn't
know the particulars about kidnapping
Jon Jones didn't know the particulars
about drag racing he didn't know that
racing your engine at the light is drag
racing a lot of people don't know that I
didn't know that I didn't know that all
now but I can see what they're doing
they're like that's how people start off
S out of 10 cops wouldn't give a
Frenchman [__] well maybe now because
there's a lot of drag racing incidents
on the five they closed the five a few
weeks ago in the daytime oh yeah that's
right but a $200,000 con when a black
man you ever watch that episode of of S
son when he gets hit in the back with a
white man by the Cadillac he wouldn't
shut the [__] up for a week
Lam man kept saying but Dad I'm telling
you I can't move my neck I
got I got hit by a white man in a
Cadillac what's he what's Fred sford
doing he's racial profiling before there
was racial profile it was
1975 uh what's his name why do I call
him red fox sain sord was racially
profiling you know Paul Mooney wrote
those episodes so [__] Paul money
wrote those okay yeah Paul money wrote
for them so you know you know [__] a
white man Cadillac and [__] hit me you
know I hit the jackpot same [__]
thing he saw a black man in the $200,000
card midnight when he pulled up he
realized it was Jon
Jones and his camera was on and you know
let this [__] ride but all that
regardless of what he was doing anybody
else was doing my argument was what the
[__] were you doing on 10 to 11 in that
[__] car 10 to
12 well I wasn't there I
don't no no no no I'm not saying it's
way a [__] opinion let me give some
sh out we'll talk about this
uh I was trying to [__] talk to you
about it before I want to thank Lou the
kid for the Animals album and the teddy
bear for my daughter you know I love you
with all my heart I love Doug
Dar Mel gabbard Brandy Lynn you know I
love you Jamie Stanley JT Joe Kylie
bonds Lance Armond trout [__] sucker
always around and Dominic Salis another
bad [__] I love so I got to give
these people shout outs I love these
[__] the animals Alum Lou no The
Animals album and he showed up at uh he
showed up at San Jose and told me he
goes I got you the it's going to take a
month to get this guy's cool as [__] so
he knows I love him with all my heart so
the reason why I was asking you about
college before I'm working out was
because I was I wanted to know how you
came up with this idea for oh man okay
and what let's start with recovery first
okay when we talk about recovery for
when I was a kid I got involved in
lifting weights I went from whatever to
whatever I knew nothing about nothing I
just knew that you did four five sets of
six and you ate 180 protein grams of
protein and you got muscles eventually
right and you kept doing that [__] and
you ran nobody told me how to mix up
workouts nobody told me how to do cables
nobody told me how to jump on tables
nobody told me how to uh you know nobody
told you nothing then you have you see
like uh Sergio believer the black dude
the black Cuban you ever see him the
bodybuilder when I was a kid I saw him
in West New York once as a kid and I
went up to him I go how do you get so
muscular and he looked at me in Spanish
and he goes Stakes like a
[__] so you know this is it and
all of a sudden we evolve and now we
have Gatorade and that's a a sports
drink that you drink when you're [__]
thirsty and then over the years you know
I was telling Lee when you and I came up
you went to health food store and for
$8.99 you bought a container of protein
an egg and milk protein and you put it
in your milk and you put Hy syrup and an
egg and wheat germ and whatever else and
you mixed it up and you drank it and if
you did two of those you got 60 grams of
protein a day and you got muscles but it
was $88.99 now I go to GNC and to buy
protein powder it's 80 [__] dollars
with 10% off with the gold card and you
know I I go to this other place for
protein it's
$49.95 and protein is just all this and
at the end of the [__] uh it's like
a$ two billion dollar business and all
of a sudden I started losing trying to
lose weight and people were saying to me
hey man what do you eat an hour after
you work out I I didn't know what they
were talking about and then Justin
Fortune's like well you should eat some
tuna with some lettuce because the
lettuce will take the acid out of your
muscles whatever is in lettuce and they
say that about marijuana and Ash too has
take the acid out of your muscles after
you work out see see I I didn't know
that about the about the lettuce or
about the has yeah so you hear all these
you I'm just saying the the different
things you hear I'm saying like when you
were talking about rules how rules have
changed over the when I was a kid you
went home and you made a milkshake with
$8.99 protein pot it was lasting you for
two months it was one [__] scoop but
over the years you know recovery then
MMA came along and then they they
started scientifically designing
different things and then uh I went to a
health food store one day to buy protein
powder and the guy goes what do you do
what are you kind of work out how you
doing I told him and he goes you know
when you do weightlifting you do an Anor
robic workout so Little Fibers get
broken so you have to rebuild those
fibers after you work out so you should
really add something to your thing so I
just used to go home and make a protein
shake you know but I I use this protein
shake now as a substitute for a meal
just to get those 30 grams no banana
just straight protein I get I keep the
carbs low so now they start talking me
about recovery so I started buying this
thing PM 360 mhm it's uh watermelon
flavor not [__] bad I like it to have
no other flavors I just took the
watermelon one day and I like how it
tast and
uh I did it for a month you know because
I'm 53 and I want every opport I don't
want to feel sore right right you know I
want to be able to do five workouts a
week and you can it's when you my AG
sometimes I do four and I can feel it
and uh another friend of mine started
saying you know you should mix up your
recoveries and all this stuff and also
I'm on the phone with you one day okay
and you you tell me about recovery so
just talk to me tell me and the people
at home well first of all I'm like you
man I I um even though I've done a
martial arts for a lot of my life I
didn't really understand a lot about um
you know diet or protein or anything I
was always eating horrible I just over
the last few years started to pay a
little bit better attention to what I
eat and the things that you know and I
realized a lot of the injuries I would
have gotten I wouldn't have gotten if I
hadn't been if I had been hydrated you
know but uh how this how uh this came
about is you know Savant Young that's
who that's who I train with fight
Academy Savant young one of his fights
he after he rehydrated with an IV this
was a few years back and he ended up
getting edema he got swelling uh he um
started retaining water and needed
medical attention so he was talking to a
friend of his a doctor and the doctor
was telling him hey that's not actually
the best way to rehydrate or or's the
best way and here are some things you
should put in there and you should make
sure you have this you should have that
then he thought about it go well here
let me get a friend and he goes well you
know we should make it a product there
this is a need for this because there's
nothing really good out the best thing
out there is is is Pedialite which is
awesome for what it is is for you know
babies after the baby's been you know
you know throwing up and pooping or
whatever you know the baby babies get
dehydrated and you need something to
help them out but the baby doesn't have
a lot on his schedule he doesn't have to
go you know fight the next day or you
know so it's perfect for that we the
needs of a depleted athlete cuz our
athletes in our sport they cut weight
and that weight cut depletes them of
their water it depletes some of their
electrolytes also need other um
micronutrients other V like magnesium
things like that also they're one of the
main things we've noticed is that the um
athletes have a hard time holding
something down so they can't get stuff
back into their system even after
they've taken the IV their their uh
enzymes in their stomach are not ready
to take in the food and get the most out
of that food they're taking in
afterwards so they're getting bloated
that's one of the things in F2 is it has
um it has things in it to reactivate the
gut and get your digestive tract working
again and so um it is going to help you
recover after that weight cut but it
also helps you recover after it's great
so recovery is recovery if you're
dehydrated if you need to uh get the
glycogen back into your muscles all
these things you need however you got
that way this has it in there for you so
I use F2 when um after I work out
especially after I've sweat I I use it
after my workouts and um I feel that
I've um that I get the most out of my
workout I used to get those gains after
that and also so I'm not wiped out like
afterwards because uh a lot of times
after some of my harder workouts I'm
wiped out for the rest of the day if I
take the if I drink the F2 I'm back in
the game and I also get more out of my
workout now when you're talking about
workout is it a weight work workout or
just a let's say you do a kickboxing
workout for an hour and a half do you
still do F2 oh definitely F2 with
something like that when you sweat so
usually let's say if I do like cuz
usually I rarely do a Weight Workout
that's without any without a
conditioning component to it so if I do
so most of my workouts are are cardio
like I'll go for a run or I'll go do
heels or if I do weights I'll do weights
first and then I'll have a uh you know a
a conditioning part to it that's going
to be that's going to be heavy and it's
going to wipe me out so um I'm defin
going to have F2 after that or after a
grappling workout cuz you know when you
grapple how much how much weight if you
have a nice long session one of those
days where you get in a few rolls you
could sweat out quite a few pounds
you're definitely going to need some F2
when I sweat out a few pounds I don't
want to put them the [__] back that's
number one but it's weird when I go over
to Albertos but see that's what's
important when you sweat out some pounds
if you sweat and lose pounds you need to
replete yourself you need to get the
water back into your system and you need
to get cuz you're going to feel better
you're going to wipe it's nice you don't
you lost the pounds and it feels good
but you're doing your body a disservice
you're going to feel better and also the
main thing is that's how the injuries
happen that's how you know you get torn
muscles when you're working out and
you're dehydrated that's how you get the
muscle tears especially at the age we
are now and I I forgive me I don't
remember if it was every athletic
commission but I think it was California
didn't one of them just ban IV okay yeah
the uh yes they did and I believe that
and the UFC does not use IVs at all
anymore so they have uh it's just part
of their their policy none of the
athletes are allowed to use IVs so so
the reasoning be cuz I I took it I'm I'm
brand new into any sort of supplements
or anything like that and I was honestly
I was nervous just because sometimes you
have something like that and it tastes
like like chemicals or something where
it tasted like lemonade to me mhm but so
when you are going to Fighters or
anything like that and saying okay you
should since you can't use IVs use this
is is it that you is it all the whole
package is it oh you're going to get
replenished cuz you you're only drinking
16 ounces of water you're not drinking a
ton of water well no because well an
athlete after he cuts weight he's going
to use more than one pack after my
workouts I use one pack after you've
done a weight cut you would use it like
you would use pedite and like the
athletes usually use uh at leis a you
know a liter to two liters some guys
guys using two and a half three lers so
that time and each one of these makes
half a liter so they would be using a
lot more than you would use after your
workout but after a workout I just use
one what do you recommend for that
package for this package how much water
16 16 o half okay now let's say you
drink one of those like I usually do I
walk in the door I put my bag down I go
right in the kitchen I put uh 16 oz in
no water thing I fill that up I shake it
up I go to I take the ghee out dry it
the knee pads the whole thing I get on
Jiu-Jitsu whatever workout and I write
down what I learned and I write down mat
time and what technique I learned I
shoot in the shower when I get out of
the shower I'm [__] thirsty again
like I'm you know that was just like an
appetizer of water right do I drink
another package of that or do I just
drink straight water this time I think I
think for you after your workouts I
think one packet and some water
afterwards and this is going to make you
want to drink some more water because
that's part of what it's supposed to do
it's going to help you absorb water so
yeah that drink one of these packets in
water now someone who's and then see how
you feel you know uh if you had a
extremely exhausting day where you might
have you know a long day and you were
dehydrated maybe two but you don't have
to do two right away you know now an
athlete after he's made weight he's
going to do two to
six what about uh what about like a
baseball player because you when when
you're watching other sports too they
always have like Tom Brady always has
this Gatorade bottle but it's not
Gatorade I don't know no I don't know
what it is is it does it work in game
yeah it's definitely going to work in
the game so like um like let's say even
for a wrestling tournament or a
jiu-jitsu tournament you know you're
going to have matches throughout the day
you're definitely going to take it if
you're playing football you're going to
definitely need to drink something like
this at halftime you know what I mean so
uh yeah it definitely works during the
game and yeah you notice the I I noticed
the difference fast I feel better right
away uh let's say you have a long night
out uh definitely drink this in the
morning maybe drink one before you go to
bed let me ask you this when I work out
and I uh go home home and I was making
the mistake of drinking a protein shake
what's the difference between me
drinking a protein shake you have
protein in yours I read the pamphlet I
talked about the carbs it's got in yours
it's better carb simple carbs well it's
got complex and so so there so there's a
from it's important to have both and how
many grams of carbs in that when when I
have that cuz most people everybody
wants to be [__] no carbs no more
right yeah yeah you know and I don't
have it with me exactly how many grams
of carbs are in here but if I have it in
here but the other thing about it is
when you do when you do do take the
carbs there's other things in here that
like like the prolinate and things like
that they're going to help you get them
into your muscles right away so that
they're not going and giving you a
glycogen Spike and especially having the
uh simple and car and the complex
there's a few things that have been done
there so that you're not the main thing
that people are avoiding carbs they
really don't want to have that that
glycogen spike is what they don't want
you
know right serving
size
uh calories yeah 24 gr mhm that's not
[__] bad at all that's perfect and
and and a lot of those aren't simple and
that's 24 G so that's not per package oh
per package it should be yeah 24 yeah
per package and a lot of those aren't um
so eight of them are complex
carbs and then 16 of them are are simple
so so how long did it take you to to
come up with this this formula and cuz
it's I can't imagine it's a like the
first mix you're like okay it's perfect
okay yeah so first of all I didn't come
up with it the guy who came up with it
is his name is Kurt Hong and he's a MD
he's a PhD he's uh went to Harvard
Medical School um cellular and molecular
pathology UCLA he's executive director
of the Center for Clinical nutrition and
applied health research at CAC School of
Medicine USC he's a nationally
recognized physician and a nutrition
specialist he wrotes for the New England
Journal of Medicine he's a really smart
guy um he's the one who came up with it
and he when he took on the task he did
some research he didn't just whip it out
you know from boiler PL I mean just his
students could whip something up but he
actually spent some time uh researching
and and put a lot of thought into this
and it took uh two and a half years and
yes it took a lot of different trial and
error The Taste wasn't right it didn't
mix right things like that a lot went
into it it's crazy how you how many ways
there are in today's society another
thing that's changed how to take care of
yourself right you know how to
really get the most of your workouts you
know uh Jesus Christ when when when I
first started [__] around with this I
never knew I'd still be interested in
this at the age of 50 I never thought
I'd be alive the 50 never mind
interested in this and I'm more
interested in Jiu-Jitsu than I ever was
anything before like it's keeping me
alive like like it's it's the anchor in
my day you know what I'm saying like
it's a great thing I like going over I
like sweating I don't care if I suck I'm
just going to keep going and eventually
I'll get it you know in time Alberto has
to give you belts he'll give you the
belt but eventually it could be at the
brown belt level one day I'll wake up
and I go oh I get it I got to pull here
and push there you know whatever uh it
doesn't matter to me like I just I have
a child and I want to be healthy for
that child and it's it's so weird how
uh you you know I've been stuck at a
certain weight for the last couple weeks
but my shirts are bigger my pants are
bigger I'm doing more in Jiu-Jitsu you
know when I first got there I couldn't
get past the [__] warm-up so my first
couple weeks was just doing the warmup
effectively doing it to form you know I
told Lee that the guy told me goes for
conditioning I just don't want you to
stop I don't believe in you going over
to the corner and breathing heavy I
don't believe in that so this is what I
want you to do he goes instead of doing
20 [__] jumping jacks do 10
do 10 of everything at first but I want
you just to work on the form and if
you're out of breath I still want you to
get in your push-up position just don't
do push-ups maybe do number three four
and five and the next time you do it do
number two but he goes I just don't want
you stopping you know and all these
little things help me like today you
know I had a Carrie Mercy from my house
to the corner today and I did it I could
never do that was it like a were you
doing like a farmer walk by yourself she
just didn't want to walk this morning to
school I'm like are you [__] serious
because my cardio [__] when I first wake
up in the morning I get real anxiety if
I could do something real quick I got to
move around a little bit I had to pick
her up and she only weighs 30 lbs but
it's a a [__] up heavy pound and I had
to walk down the [__] street with it
and I kept making personal goals to
myself I make it to the tree I'll put it
down and I made it to the tree and I
could still breathe I just slowed down a
little bit but kept holding her and even
though felt like putting it down I go if
I can make it to that driveway and I
made it all the way to the [__]
corner and I was dead oh my God I
started [__] sweating from every AR I
couldn't stop my body went into shock
but you know what 6 weeks ago I couldn't
walk to the corner with her not even
close Jiu-Jitsu right not even close no
breathing breathing it's not Jiu-Jitsu
it's I I wasn't breathing I was holding
and I still catch myself over there
holding my breath Saturday yeah this
Saturday I'm going to a breathing sem
and Anthony hardock school okay he's
doing she's not she's a
lady she's doing time of flex so I'm
going to go down I've been talking to
that lady for about four months now
we've been talking on the phone and she
gives me a little exercises to do but
this week I'm going down Saturday from
4: to 7: yeah I'm going to go work that
out I'm taking the steroids now to lower
the inflammation in my nose so when I go
back to the doctor I could breathe a
little better I get this times I'll take
like a a a shroom Tech that's an on it
that's a quadricep mushroom that gives
you more oxygen when you're breathing
sometimes I get so much oxygen from
those room Texs I got anxiety too much
[__] air you know what I'm saying
like too much is coming in and I'm
[__] I got to try those yeah I should
have got you some I just got the last
thing and I've been I opened it up if
not I would have brought you some but
I'll get you some quad some shroom Tech
Sport and some shroom Tech immune okay
that're [__] good they're really good
you know if you fly the shroom Tech
immune is good and if you work out out
the shroom Tech sport is really good cuz
it's those mushrooms that are growing up
in high altitude so it's It prepares
your body for high altitude you know
Rogan explain a lot more to you you got
to go on on and I'm terrible when it
comes to that [__] man and now how can
they get this how can they get the so
they can get to F2 fight formula at uh
F2 fight formula.com and you know follow
us on Instagram uh F2 fight formula
you'll be able to find it in there and
uh yeah you'll be able to get at f2
fight formula.com just punching in uh go
to the website you can buy it right
there one flavor uh it's Citrus flavor
yeah it's like a citrus kind of it's
good it's good it's a good flavor and
what I like about it is I did not
realize for me the biggest thing about
this is I didn't realize that how I'm
normally deplete it whether I've been
working out or not just because I don't
pay enough attention to my hydration or
to the getting these micronutrients in
and so taking this two or three times a
week after my workouts I have a general
overall better feel feeling like
everything feels better and that's what
I noticed that's the biggest thing I I
noticed about it and it's like I feel
like man it's a shame that I spent a lot
of my life depleted and not taking care
of myself you know whenever I go for a
blood test they always say drink more
water MH you're not drinking enough
water and I think it's the [__]
Edibles especially if I eat one of them
at night you wake up at 400 in the
morning thirsty as [__] Jack thirsty as
[__] so the ref school is sold out yeah
yeah yeah you know so the um I'm going
to be doing my ref school on June 3rd
4th and 5th uh it's it's full so I'm
going to be probably doing another date
soon people are reaching out to me I'm
actually going to start uh uh taking
people for the next date I'll probably
do it in fall in during the fall usually
I only do it once a year but it seems
like a lot of people want to do one and
also I want to keep the size of the
class low because it's just better when
I work with I mean you know when I work
with groups of over 20 it's too many
people so I keep it definitely under 20
right around 15 is good so I think I'm
going going to drop it up into two
classes this year so I'll do another one
probably around October and then go to
the web page yeah go to Herb dean.com
[__] her.com and check it out yeah what
do you got planned for the weekend over
there [__] I'm not sure I I'm not going
to see Paul this weekend so I'm just I
might go to kettle bells 8 in the
morning on Saturday they were they were
trying to convince me to do it today and
I was like 8 in the morning that's tough
but who teaches I think Dave I'm pretty
sure Dave does but it's uh that's that's
it I'm going to do that I'm going to uh
I just did a life and neutral yesterday
just kind of relax all right yeah what
what you got coming up my brother oh man
this weekend I'm at home so I'm going to
relax I'm going to have a good time and
just enjoy La it's going to be it's a
rarity for me you know and then the next
couple weeks the UFC kicks up again yeah
so yeah after this this weekend so this
weekend I'll be home then after that I
think uh where I go this next oh this
next one I think I go down to Florida
and then after Florida I come back and
go to Vegas for that's the Tampa one
yeah Tampa that's the one that the
Russian the kid fell out yeah then on on
the oh he fell out yeah oh Ki fell out
yeah and then um the 30th I'm going to
go I'm either going to go someone
invited me to go down to um Trinidad
Tobago and referee some fights I really
want to do that but this guy he hasn't
contacted me so I might I just got
someone just invited me to go to China
so I'm going to make sure he wants me to
come I'm either going to be in Trinidad
or I'm going to be in
China yeah then getting all those
frequent fly miles yeah man I try to
stay busy you know then sometime or
another I'm go to Korea then may
yeah and then you got all the UFC dates
you on everything you do the Bellator
yeah you do I do whatever if somebody
calls me I go and referee it that's what
I like to do you got [__] to do and
people to [__] see that's right
it's just good to see you man I was
supposed to fly with you a couple weeks
ago the last uh UFC the Conor McGregor
one we're going to meet 11:30 in flly
right yeah yeah but uh I had to move my
I had an audition so I had to move my
flight later on and as I was moving I go
[__] I told herd I meet him at the
[__] Airport yeah when when um when's
the next show that you're doing Friday
I'm in h Santa Barbara with Joe and Tony
henchcliffe Friday you guys are doing
Santa Barbara this Friday and then I'm
off all next week and then I'll be at
the comedy store and then the two weeks
after that I'm in h Buffalo at Helium
mhm which I dig Buffalo and then I'm in
Indianapolis and I dig Indianapolis so
there two good weeks back to back right
that sounds like fun I got Sacramento
and I got Pittsburgh oh okay then I got
Omaha Nebraska and I got
Philadelphia I got the ice house I got
Vegas with Joe for UFC 200 and the
Expo I got Nashville I got New York
Austin Columbus Chicago Las Vegas [__] I
got a hell of a schedule all the way to
the end of the year when people ask you
your favorite place are you good at
picking out favorites I'm horrible at
picking out people pick out ask me to
pick out favorite stuff I can't can't
pick out a favorite I always think about
it I always think about it when I go
home and here's the deal that it's
favorite for a certain thing
right like you know what I'm saying
that's all cuz I I like going listen if
I I go to your city one time I don't
like it I won't go back right right I'm
one of those [__] dudes I just but
I've always found the beauty where I go
like yeah there's always a reason that
something gets me psyched up about that
area right even know if there's a hot
dog stand in front of the hotel I just
went somewhere where they had a hot dog
stand in front of the hotel I didn't eat
any hot dogs but it made me happy just
know there's [__] sabed hot dog
stand in front of the [__] hotel
Charlotte charot the week before the
Super Bowl a sad bre stand not just a
hot dog stand but a Saad bread stand but
no I'm only kid yet just different
things like Buffalo I like uh the people
and I like the [__] beef on Wick
sandwich okay Indianapolis this is one
place I went to eat that was really good
a steak place they made like a 6 o filet
with a nice salad [__] delicious and
uh I like the people the people have to
be the best thing about that City you
know I like the people when I go to
Texas you know uh and then there's
places that I don't like but we all
conserve there we all Converse there
like you know what I'm saying like when
you perform in Vegas I don't really have
a home in Vegas but the south point when
I do the shows with Joe a lot of the
same people come to those shows so it's
nice seeing them you know right right
when I go to Austin I got a certain
amount of people you see you see Bobby
Sharon when you go to Chicago you see
the crazy dude in the [__] wheelchair
Michael Kar shows up to all your shows
so you start having relationships with
different people people coming
yeah you know they coming you know when
I like some of these like this guy who
sent you the right like he came to San
Jose okay so that's one of the guys who
come sees your right Brandy Lynn came to
Minneapolis Jamie Stanley came to Boston
and sure come to Connecticut you know
people like that they come to different
shows and you keep and you you know the
people okay I mean I think that I have
great supporters and great people uh in
the sport I have a lot of people who
follow me and and support me but usually
when they reach out they want something
from me none of them ever reach out to
give me little gifts like this yeah you
know we I'm man I'm I'm going to put I
need to well we give each other
something we give each other something
you know what I'm saying like we just uh
we give time and we talk and sometimes
people email me or sometimes we talk
about something that's a subject they've
been thinking about you know we did a
podcast Monday it was just me and him
people really dug it because we we spoke
about breaking down different subjects I
got tormented about saying I don't like
[__] cartoons people got pissed off
at me and [__] adult cartoons I hate
adult cartoons I hate it I just hate how
people get addicted to them and you're a
[__] adult get out of the house if
you're telling me you're at home jerking
off watching porn I get it but when I
ask you what are you doing satday night
you're telling me you're staying home to
watch The Avengers or something cuz uh
death man is on the episode I want to
shoot you like I want to [__] shoot
you as a goddamn adult but that's just
my own personal [__] taste on people
you know sometimes you just got pissed
off so but I'm happy you I hadn't seen
you in a while man yeah no it's good
back on and just talk some [__] on a
Wednesday afternoon you know it's nice I
like your new uh your new digs here it's
nice yeah no we don't [__] around here
this is uh the office of debt that's
right we got the hash bite we got the
record player you know you can't lose in
this [__] a mini fridge that's
all you need a mini fridge I mean uh
yeah this is as good as it gets brother
thank you for coming on let me give a
shout out to my sponsors and we'll get
you the [__] out of here unless you got
to go now whatever you want to do we'll
just take five more minutes here I
already gave a shout out but let me do
it again my people that on it who I love
with all my heart the hemp Force protein
I love the the the you know I live on
the shroom Tech Sport and the shroom
Tech immune I just got the Alpha Brain
and little packages that you could just
do individual like in the water bottle
bam I bam those out before Jiu-Jitsu you
know before I'm going to ride or
something I'm going to stay up and ride
or when I get up early and ride I drink
my coffee I take my [__] heart uh
pressure medication and then I pop some
Alpha brand with some breakfast and I
start writing whatever so listen man uh
hit's been there for me with the Alpha
Brain Lee and I were talking about it
how they give you 100% money back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
product cuz it's their [__] uh
Flagship it's their Flagship so when
somebody does that you kind of go you
know what I'll try their other stuff I
can sit here for hours and tell you
about on it [__] it do me a favor go to
the web page and look at all their
supplements from the from the tea
testosterone booster to the shroom Tech
to the they just have so many things and
every week they're upd new you know au's
out there [__] in the jungles of Peru
getting different herbs for you and
whatnot but do me a favor go to h.com
right now take a look at the great
selection of supplements they have if
you see something you like go to the box
add it in there and get 10% off but
before you check out what do you press
Le pressing the word church CH H Ur CH
and your 10% off your order delivered
right to your [__]
door okay just like you with your
product can I can I can hit this again
yeah yeah yeah so uh if you need some
fight formula what you do everybody
needs fight formula F2 fight formula.com
and if you're interested in anything I'm
doing like my referee sco herb dean.com
see what I'm saying F2 fight formula.com
who's better than you and he does it
with the icing Hay's smooth
[__] voice you know what I'm
saying number two like Lee said it's
baseball season [__] it's hot
it's time to get out there you know
Dodgers uh were home last week I think
I'm home next week I'm going to leave
here and look at the schedule that's one
of the things I want to do you know and
uh what's the next big event you want to
go to you know you want to go to I want
to go to Black Sabbath at the Hollywood
Bowl I want to go to David Gilmore
Monday night at the Garden I want to go
to a a Dodger game next week whatever it
is you can bet that someone's going to
pay less for better seats how let me
tell you how they use scorebig.com
that's how you're paying too much for
tickets I talk about on the show
constantly how these look I got a Lakers
shirt on today you think I could afford
to go to a Laker game hell no between
all the markups and the last minute
convenience charges even the print at
home fees you end up paying Courtside
prices for nose bleed seats scorebig.com
is here to change this all right did you
know that 40% of all Live Events go
unsold all the live event tickets go
unsold did you know that there's a place
to get these seats at huge savings you
know what it's called
scorebig.com
scorebig works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get their
unsold seats at unpublished prices only
at scorebig.com can you name a ticket
price name a ticket price and be
guaranteed to pay below box office up to
60% off here's exactly what you do one
go to scorebig.com and find the event
and the seat that you want two make an
offer with score Big's name a ticket
price feature three get an instant
answer and save up to 60% % on your
ticket it's baseball season it's
America's [__] game get it together
[__] no surprise free no surprise
fees and free shipping [__] just
unbeatable prices on great seats and
when you're in great seats you actually
enjoy the game and the show a lot more
so do me a favor next time you see any
game or show next time you want to go
see any gamer show go to score big first
and see how much you can save go to
scorebig.com right now click on the
microphone enter the promo code Joey the
promo code is Joey Jo oey and you'll
save an extra 20% off your first ticket
price okay that's scorebig.com promo
code Joey scorebig.com promo code Joey
to get 60% off at your name your price
tickets all right there you go so don't
say I didn't [__] tell you go to
scorebig.com right now also very
important I'm doing this breathing
seminar so today I saw the post on
Facebook about maximize your breathing
and I went on I've heard about this
she's amazing hers is great and one of
the things she talks about in there is
meditation I didn't take the class but
one of the things she talks about in
that breeding is meditating and I get
what she's saying when you see the high
level Javier Vasquez those high level
Jiu-Jitsu guys they breathe a certain
way they breathe as they move and what
she's saying is what I'm trying to say
is that you just keep breathing and not
stop once you stop it's like [__] you
fall behind the eightball you're done
but one of the things he talks about was
meditate all right meditation like I
said I I I didn't know dick about
meditation so I got confused and Boulder
and I started going up to shiak on
Monday nights for walking meditation and
then I started doing it sitting down and
thinking about it and visualizing and
it's all great and dandy it really does
work but let's be honest most of your
PRS start with your mind fear anger
stress anxiety depression sleeplessness
they begin get in your head but they can
wreck your life okay and we all know
that but it doesn't have to be that way
you can make a major difference in just
10 minutes a day 10 minutes a day this
change comes through guided meditation
with the new headspace app heads space
is meditation Made Simple it's guided
meditations that you listen to whenever
you want wherever you want right on your
phone computer or tablet meditation is
rooted in thousands of years of
tradition with thousands I'm talking
thousands of scientific studies that
show its positive effects like improving
Focus relationship Harmony and
decreasing anxiety and stress join over
4 million users already getting some
headspace for free right now do me a
favor man uh I had this anxiety stuff
and I downloaded the 10 steps that
they're talking about in here the 10
take program it's a headspace Ab and
it's a take 10 program take 10 program
and I'll tell you what I haven't had
that much anxiety it's just breathing
it's just looking straight ahead closing
your eyes working on your third eye You
Know download the head the free
headspace app and begin the take 10
program for 10 days of guided meditation
at headspace.com Joey the headspace
take10 program is 100% free way to
experience the benefits of meditation in
your busy Modern Life train your mind
for a healthier less stressed life start
with your free trial today go to
headspace.com
Joey that's headspace that's
headspace.com / Joey all right and do me
a favor if you want to reference
anything go to Andy pacom Ted Talk which
is over 5 million views it should come
up to Google any P Petty just Google
Andy pettom Ted Talk Andy's the founder
headspace and the voice you hear on the
app all right you don't need to put
aside loads of time or immigrate to
Tibet Andy did that for you just do me
one favor go to headspace.com
joeey and start your free trial today
all right I want to thank headspace
score big on it and my main
[__] man Herb Dean for coming
down today and turning us on to some F2
and we talked about music and everything
the [__] else thank you my brother thank
you and I you I will see you at UFC 200
yeah yeah okay see you there brother all
right Lee what's up with you my brother
um just yeah just go check out life in
neutral Johnny Rock and I he's a young
comic in La we had a great time
yesterday it's been we've done about 14
episodes and it's growing uh and that's
it I have T-shirts for selling Ed go to
lisa.com but I had a great time and uh
I'll see you guys next week stay black
[__]
suckers you got t-shirts he's got
t-shirts he's got everything we don't
[Music]
[__]
[Applause]
[Music]
and night I walk this stinging Street
past the crazy on my block and I see the
same old faces and I hear that same old
talk and I'm searching for the latest
thing I break in this routine I'm
talking some new kicks on likeing you
ain't never seen this
[Music]
is this is me
Street
oh the only one I
know and we don't worry back tomorrow
cuz we're sick of these fall walls now
what you think is nothing might be
something after all now you know this
ain't no through Street The End Is Dead
Ahead the poor folks play for deeps down
here they're the Living Dead come on
down
down to me
street they dancing
[Applause]
now me
street dance
[Music]
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all here now my friend it ain't
want upon a time it's all over but the
shouting I come to take what's m
we're searching for the latest thing I
break in this routine talking some new
kicks on like you ain't never seen this
is
[Music]
home this is me
street
it's only one I
know this is all see a gun is real
easy in this desperate part of time